a equals 7 for this equation. Great work if you found this answer. This
equation had two radicals. So, we want to split them up, so one radical is on
each side of the equals sign. We add this square root to both sides of the
equation to get our new one. Now we can undo these square roots by raising both
sides to the second power. We'll have 4a minus 3 equal to 2a plus 11. We solved
this linear equation by subtracting 2a from both sides, then adding 3 and
dividing by 2. This gives us a is equal to 7. Now, like every problem before,
you want to check this answer in the original equation. We plug in the value of
7 in for a, here and here. And then we get the expression, root 24 minus root
24, on the left-hand side. We know this equals 0. So, yes, 0 does equal 0,
which means our solution checks.